getting out of myself that's the tricky
part I've always been fascinated by
people who position themselves as being
tough in themselves especially when they
are quick to bring out that everybody
around them always says that they're too
tough on themselves because it means
that they've been effectively
storytelling to the people around them
that they're too hard of themselves
which is actually a very on paper
admirable kind of positioning I would
ask yourself when you go to sleep
tonight and you think about this are you
interested in positioning yourself to
the people around you as someone who is
hard on themselves or are you hard on
yourself do you understand it's
interesting work you have to look inside
because I think it's a smart way to
position yourself as a protection
mechanism to give you time on your
journey so you're not judged while
you're on your journey
foreign